[Music]
so tonight with any luck the world
series will come to a close um if the
braves beat the astros in game six
they'll have won the series and the
world champion trophy and best of all
the baseball season will finally be over
it's not that i hate baseball anytime i
try to watch it i can't stay awake long
enough to develop any strong feelings
about it but i do think that baseball is
a fine activity for children especially
fat children who need some physical
activity but aren't fit enough to play a
real sport yet i think it's great for
that
my main issue with baseball as a
spectator sport is that it involves far
too much standing and sitting
at any given moment during any play 95
of people on both sides have nothing to
do
the entire team on offense is sitting
down except for the guy at bat and then
on defense
the majority of the guys in the field
won't be involved in the play even if
the batter hits the ball
if i want to watch people standing or
sitting around bored and despondent
interspersed with brief moments of
moderate physical exertion i'll go to
the dmv or the post office or something
so it's just a long way of saying that
baseball has some problems
these are all practical problems and
problems that can't be fixed except by
introducing you know i don't know you
could introduce tackling to baseball or
maybe by arming the outfielders with
paintball guns i'm not sure what that
would do exactly but
i'm just thinking out loud brainstorming
or else we might need a constitutional
amendment to simply abolish baseball
entirely uh the media on the other hand
has been focused on trying to find other
problems in baseball aside from the fact
that it's you know boring as hell
for them of course
uh the problem is not entertainment
for them it's always about race and as
the season is coming to a close they are
in a mad dash to find some way to
racialize baseball the fact that the
braves are involved has provided them
with obvious fodder so here's cnn says
native groups and advocates are
demanding that the atlanta braves
eliminate the tomahawk champ chop symbol
and gesture from its branding and game
day traditions saying the team is
perpetuating racist stereotypes as the
braves take the national stage in the
world series leaders from the native
community said this week it's past time
for the braves to join other
professional sports teams such as the
cleveland
guardians and washington football team
in removing offensive imagery and
mascots which they say reduce native
people down to caricatures
now you'll be shocked to learn that joy
reid over on msnbc agrees that it's
racist for braves fans to do the
tomahawk chop then again she thinks the
fans if they're white are racist no
matter what they do i mean they're
racist when they breathe they're racist
when they walk into the stadium the
racist when they put their pants on in
the morning
the tomahawk chop is just the racist
cherry on top of the bigoted cake so
let's listen to joy reid
the world series between the atlanta
braves and the houston astros is
happening now shifting to the stadium in
atlanta for the next three games which
means viewers across the country will
soon be subjected to a particular show
of fandom that has roiled baseball for
decades
and that's the tomahawk chop correction
the racist tomahawk chop a synchronized
movement of the arm by atlanta fans at
home games a gesture and chant promoting
stereotypes caricatures and frankly
hatred of native american people the
chop gets its world series spotlight
starting tomorrow
as other teams are retiring such
appropriation the washington football
team ditched its former name a racial
slur we will not be repeating here and
the cleveland indians banished their
extremely offensive logo and also
changed their name to the guardians
this week baseball commissioner rob
manfred came out in defense of atlanta
saying quote the native american
community in that region is fully
supportive of the braves program
including the chop but yeah no
because native americans and allies have
protested the chop for at least 30 years
including actual native american
baseball players like cardinals reliever
ryan helsley a member of the cherokee
nation who was forced to pitch amid the
chop when his team faced the braves
the national congress of american
indians responded to manfred saying
native people are not mascots degrading
rituals like the tomahawk chop that
dehumanize and harm us have no place in
american society
well yeah i'm sorry let's back up for a
second the tomahawk chop promotes hatred
of native americans
is that what you think these fans are
saying to themselves as they move their
arms like that damn native americans i
hate them damn them
um i find that unlikely in fact if you
if you hate a certain person or certain
type of person you wouldn't want to pay
tribute to them in that way you also
wouldn't want them as a mascot
if a mascot is supposed to be some kind
of degrading insult
why doesn't any team name themselves i
don't know the nazis how about the
atlanta nazis
maybe that should be the new name
i mean if that's the idea right with a
mascot you're supposed to be insulting
somebody
but if they did that i'm quite sure that
the joyrides of the world would combust
from pure outrage accusing the team of
promoting and celebrating nazism and in
that case she would be correct that's
because a mascot is meant to be a
positive thing a promotion a celebration
indian mascots and chants are a tribute
to native americans not an insult
why do native american words and imagery
make for good sports mascots well
because
native american culture was a warrior
culture that's what the tomahawk chant
uh and chop specifically hearkens back
to and pays homage to indians were
warring people that's a historical fact
there's no reason to hide from it or
deny it the effort to remove all of the
native american themes from sports is
part of a larger
uh uh you know effort to sanitize indian
culture and its history
to feminize and sterilize it
to paint the indians as helpless weak
victims rather than the formidable
forceful
and ferocious people that they often
were
this is something that the left wishes
to do in the past and the present as
native americans of today are portrayed
as petty you know limp sorts of people
who are constantly crying over sports
mascots somehow gravely injured by team
names and stadium chants
i don't think that the majority really
are so fragile
and for anyone of any racial or ethnic
group who is that fragile to be that
upset about a team mascot
it's all the more reason
not to bend to their whim
and give them everything they want
and so the people complaining about
racism here are of course cancelled but
i also have to say that for non-racial
reasons uh baseball as well is cancelled
so all of that is cancelled and we all
we tie together in a nice bow as
baseball hopefully comes to a merciful
close tonight we can only pray
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated